first of all congratulations can we talk
about that full circle moment that
happened tonight i mean you used to
babysit paris hilton and here she is
presenting the award with you it was
crazy i don't think most people know
that story about paris did you know that
you did you did yeah it was a full
circle moment there were more full
soccer moments my daughter is 12 and
that's how old paris was when i was
watching her farrah who's kyle's
daughter was at the table and i knew her
when she was four that i mean kathy i
used to work with
for
because of kyle i mean it was just like
a full so many full circles but really
nice so many generations of reality tv
stars i mean it's kind of crazy do you
think we have a future reality tv star
in your daughter
i don't think so because she likes me
off of the housewife she i have a new tv
show that will be coming fairly soon
that's not in this genre it's a genre
but uh she likes being with me she likes
she likes
time and she doesn't like me sort of
arguing and getting into nonsense i mean
she's very
she's a
high-class little girl she wants no part
of it she doesn't want to flip tables
and none of that she's a sweet little
freedom
artist and it must be so special to
share moments like this with her because
she's old enough not to like remember
it's it just started six months ago
where i started bringing her to things
and now she gets it and she sees how
hard i work and she was tearing up and
it's really sweet it's really nice so
the jersey shore cast received the same
award last year and now it's you who do
you think should be the reality royalty
next year my goodness reality royalty
next year
i need a minute to think i don't know
maybe um
i don't know if it has to be someone
from the housewives but
i don't know exactly what it has to
entail maybe rupaul there you go
yeah rupaul should be the next year's
reality royalty facts we're manifesting
that one right there what give me
somebody else give me somebody better i
was gonna say paris hilton what if you
present to paris next year paris and
nicole together that's right no because
next year paris because she's had more
of a varied career in reality tv paris
hilton i can't believe let's let's
retract before paris hilton should be
the next year yeah next year is the 20th
anniversary of the simple life
let's not tell her it's a very simple
life and a very simple conversation
paris hilton next year i'll present you
have it right there